a warning the following report from our
political correspondent Joe Pike does
contain some Flash images
the BBC's boss is locked in a standoff
with its highest paid Star Mr Dave are
you the man sought out the crisis of the
BBC director General Tim Davies made in
partiality his Central Mission but that
effort to protect the corporation has
left the organization in crisis it is
not impartial for the BBC to cave in
to Tory MPS
complaining about Gary lineker it's the
opposite of impartial whilst labor are
now sided with Mr lineker Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt has told the male the
remarks were offensive and it is deeply
regrettable he hasn't apologized he's
got a train to catch meanwhorishi sunak
whose policy was initially being
criticized has avoided taking sides he
said in a statement Gary lineker was a
great footballer and is a talented
presenter I hope that the current
situation between Gary denica and the
BBC can be resolved in a timely manner
but it is rightly a matter for them not
the government
commenting on government policy and
comparing the rhetoric around it to
1930s Germany does seem to breach the
BBC's editorial guidelines but as a
freelance presenter not working in news
should these rules even apply to Gary
lineker the BBC's guidelines say there
are others who are not journalists or
involved in factual programming who
nevertheless have an additional
responsibility to the BBC because of
their profile on the BBC we expect these
individuals to avoid taking sides on
party political issues or political
controversies and to take care when
addressing public policy matters yet
critics of the corporation argue the
rules weren't applied fairly when
Apprentice host Alan sugar made comments
about Jeremy corbyn online or political
interviewer Andrew Neal tweeted about
brexit
add to that the controversy around BBC
chairman and Tori donor Richard Sharp he
helped facilitate an 800 000 pound loan
to Boris Johnson why didn't you disclose
it the um
just to be clear I didn't I didn't
arrange the loan I did at the meeting
helped with the law and some argue he
should now go I think that I'd been in
his position I'd resigned immediately
but if he's not prepared to do that then
he should certainly be suspended while
the inquiries go on after all Gary
lineker is being suspended while they
work out what the policy on tweet should
be this isn't the first time Gary
lineker's political comments have made
headlines and as the face of the
corporation Sports coverage that clearly
concerns Tim Davey but the director
General does have a difficult Balancing
Act to try and pull off leading an
organization which holds those in power
to account whilst being reliant on the
government to approve any future funding
settlement but the longer the standoff
the larger the damage to the reputation
of the beleaguered BBC Joe Pike Sky News